you need to be the person that you want
to be most the time that's who he's got
to love
same goes the other way around too guys
don't like put on a suit and go on a
date if you hate suits and now you're
the guy with the suit so you feel like
you always got to be the guy with the
suit no
go somewhere and be yourself if you're
the ripped jeans and t-shirt guy be that
guy if she doesn't like that guy she
doesn't like you you're not for her
let's get that out of the way on date
one
okay if she wants to go to a fancy
restaurant every time and you're not a
fancy restaurant kind of guy that could
be a problem if you invite her to go for
a walk and that's not good enough for
her because she needs a more expensive
dinner and she wants you dressed nicer
and that's not who you are how you spend
your days that's not gonna work so from
the beginning just be yourself if it
meshes it meshes if it doesn't wow
amazing you know on day one Don't Force
It
don't be like oh but she's so cute don't
do that she's still gonna be cute on day
10 only you're not gonna be smiling
you're going to be like oh why can't I
just she's so cute but